in the last video we learned a little
bit about what an income statement would
look like for a very kind of vanilla
company that sent that sells widgets and
in this video what I wanted to do is
kind of close the loop and see how this
relates to what we talked about in the
first video in terms of price per share
and we'll talk about earnings per share
in this case and also how the income
statement relates to the balance sheet I
said I would do it in the last video but
then I realized I was running out of
time and this is a bit of a quick review
and you probably just watched that video
but just in case you didn't revenue was
literally the widgets that I sold I sold
let's say this was for 2008 I sold three
million dollars worth of widgets cost of
goods sold well that's just the cost of
the goods sold so I sold a milli the the
three million dollar the three million
let's say I sold three million widgets
for $1 to produce those three million
widgets for $1
it cost me maybe thirty cents a widget
or thirty three cents of widget and so I
had a total expense or total cost of
goods sold of a million dollars and so
the profit from just selling those let's
say in that case that I just made up
three million widgets or three million
dollars worth of widgets was two million
dollars but I have other expenses I
can't just put that in my pocket had
marketing sales general and
administrative and then I was left with
a million dollars and that's how much
operating profit the my my little widget
my widget company has produced but I'm
not done yet in the last video I I
didn't own the company outright I had
some debt in this case five million
dollars worth of debt so I had to pay
some interest there was 10% interest so
you take the interest out you're left
with $500,000 of pre-tax income and of
course you have to pay the government
and you know we can debate on whether
we're paying them too much or too little
but you know they're providing me a
defense so that you know other foreign
countries can't come and bomb my
factories and they're providing and
hopefully an educated workforce for me
and nice roads and infrastructure and
electricity so who know so that's what
I'm paying for or arguably and so I'm
left with net income of $350,000 and
when people talk about earnings of a
company this is what they're talking
about this net income is also earnings
earnings so when someone says Google
made four billion dollars this past
quarter and quarter just means a quarter
of a year or three month period and they
normally are literally you know March
June September and December so every
fourth of the year they're literally
saying Google made three billion dollars
in net income now what if you know we
talked in the first video when we
started the series about different
companies have different number of
shares so let's write let's just make up
a number of shares for this company so
let's say this company has let's say
shares let me do it in move so this
company shares let's say it has 1
million shares 1 million shares so
you've probably heard not only the term
earnings you've probably also heard the
term earnings per share so what they do
is they just take your earnings number
and you divide by the number of shares
and you have earnings per share or EPS
sometimes people just say EPS for this
company and 2008 was and in this case
you take $350,000 just your total
earnings divided by the total number of
shares you have and that's what that's
35 cents 35 cents per share of EPS now
you've probably heard actually before I
go into into something you know I before
I go into price to earnings and all of
that I want to connect the dots between
the income statement and the balance
sheet so in this period I made three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars so
what the way you can think about what an
income statement is is it tells you what
happens between balance sheet snapshots
so let's say at the beginning of let's
say on 12 31 12 31 2007 the balance
sheet for the company would have looked
like this let me just draw it I won't
use the square tool so it had 10 million
dollars of assets 10 million dollars of
assets it had 5 million dollars of debt
5 million dollars you can kind of
this is the liabilities of which debt is
one of them let's just it's all of it so
five million dollars of liabilities so
the shareholders equity or you could
almost be the Book value of the company
the book value of the equity of the
company is $5,000,000 $5,000,000 equity
five million dollar equity and just to
make the kind of tied a little bit with
what we did at the at the in the first
video if we have a million shares we
have a million shares the book value of
the equity is five million so if we say
the book value book value per share is
just going to be this number divided by
the million shares I have so five
million divided by 1 million is five
dollars this is the book value per share
remember there's a difference between
Book value and market value this the the
the stock of this company at 12:31 2007
it could have been trading at $10 at $7
at $1 thousand the market value per
share this is the book value and the
book value is essentially saying okay if
you take the the book value of the
assets and I talked about this a little
bit in the last video but if you say oh
well you know we paid ten million
dollars and you know this is how much
value there and I'll go into more detail
into how you value these type of things
and you take out the liabilities this is
what the assets are worth according to
the accountants the market value could
be very different but fair enough I
don't want to delve too much into that
but now over this period of time over
2008 2008 happens so the rest of 2008
happens and we're left at the end of
let's say it 1 1 2009 or we could say 12
31 2008 doesn't matter you know give or
take a day it's a holiday anyway we have
a new balance sheet right we have a new
balance sheet but what happened here
over the course of the year we earned
some money and I won't go too
complicated into you know cash and and
accrual accounting and all of that right
now we will get into that eventually but
I just want to get you the gist of
what's happening is that we made three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
this year so our assets will have
increased by three hundred fifty
thousand dollars if this was it
have increased by $350,000 of cash it
might have been increased by just other
people saying they owe us $350,000 those
are accounts receivables I'll make a
whole video probably a whole series of
videos on accounts receivables it just
says that it's an asset that says
someone owes me that money but anyway
you think about it our assets will have
increased by this amount of money over
the course of the year so now our new
balance sheet at the end of 2008
so 2008 happened let me draw 2008 2008
happens at the end of which our assets
would have grown a little bit our assets
are now at ten million three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars so I'll put this
in thousands right this is ten thousand
three hundred fifty thousand so that's
the same thing as ten point three five
million right and let's see we haven't
all we did is we paid the interest on
the debt in this example we just paid
interest and just so you know most
corporate debt actually works that way
we'll talk later about amortization
schedules and how can you pay down the
debt but unlike mortgages a lot of
corporate debt they just pay the
interest so we still have the same
amount of debt we didn't pay down any of
the principle of the debt so we still
have five million dollars of debt and
what's left over for the equity well all
of our earnings since our debt stayed
the same all of our earnings actually
falls down straight to equity so we have
five million three hundred fifty
thousand dollars of equity so the way I
think about it and probably the way you
think about you should think about is
the earnings of a company the earnings
of a company in this case we have three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars for
the year or thirty five cents per share
they essentially tell you what happened
from one balance sheet to another so
this tells you that this number the
amount that this number grows by the
amount that our equity grows by is
earnings so this is three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
earnings $350,000 of earnings and
there's something I might want to touch
on because in the last video I talked a
little bit about return on asset where
we just took the operating profit and we
divide that by the assets we had a 10%
return on assets you might say oh well
why shouldn't the assets grow by that
amount and the reason they didn't grow
by that amount is because we actually
ended up having to pay taxes on some of
that even if we had no debt we would
still have to pay taxes just this line
would have disappeared so sometimes when
people talk about return on asset which
I did in that last video it might be
interesting to say is that the pre-tax
or the post tax return on asset in this
example that I did in the previous video
it was the pre-tax return on asset but
fair enough I think that's an in this
connection that income that balance
sheets are just snapshots in time
they're kind of like your bank account
how much are you worth at any one moment
and income statements tell you how do
you get from one balance sheet to the
next balance sheet and we'll learn later
that the the cash flow statement
essentially reconciles the income
statement with what happens with your
actual cash accounts or how things
actually move within the balance sheet
and we'll do that later on but anyway we
started off in this video talking about
oh you know what's cheap what's
expensive and so the question is how do
you determine that if you can't just go
by the actual dollar price of the my my
baby is crying I should probably run to
that let me do that right now I realize
I'm already at ten minutes I'll see you
in the next video